parce qu'on a envie de dire que ça vous
avantage presque céline maglica cette
configuration là alors moi être contre
un parti qui n'est pas républicain non
ça ne m'avantage pas moi je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier les électrices et
les électeurs qui nous ont fait
confiance qui se sont mobilisés et je
les appelle vraiment à se mobiliser le
29 mars
parce que nous ne sommes pas face à un
parti traditionnel qui voudraient faire
croire qu'il n'est pas d'extrême droite
c'est un parti qui est effectivement est
un parti fantôme que nous n'avons pas du
tout vu dans la campagne à part quelques
affiches n'y a eu aucune présence sur le
terrain aucune proposition concrète
on nous parle sans arrêt de politique
nationale mais on est dans une élection
départementale et cette élection
départementale elles touchent la vie des
gens elle touche les personnes
handicapées elle touche les personnes
âgées la petite enfance les collèges les
transports la voirie ce sont des choses
concrètes et nous on propose des choses
concrètes
effectivement nous n'avons pas le même
programme que la droite nous pensons
qu'une autre politique départementale
est possible avec au coeur de toutes les
solidarités les valeurs de fraternité
les valeurs républicaines que nous aussi
nous portons et nous pensons
effectivement qu'il est grave d'être
face à un front national qui est un
parti qui prône des idées extrémistes
contre lesquelles nous nous battrons
avec détermination avec ténacité et je
peux vous dire que le courage politique
nous l'aurons c'est très fort mais l'a
amené la parité il faut le rappeler
nous étions très 13 % de femmes dans les
conseils généraux nous serons 50% demain
et je peux vous dire que c'est avec
beaucoup de courage politique que nous
affronterons cet adversaire qui nous
semble dangereux pour notre république
voulait répondre